hablemos del sistema cardiovascular aquí
hice un dibujo simplificado de este
tenemos el corazón que es la bomba que
envía la sangre por los vasos sanguíneos
alrededor de todo el cuerpo el propósito
de todo este sistema es llevar sangre a
esta sección al lecho capilar y es aquí
donde los vasos sanguíneos se vuelven
muy delgados y se dividen y por ser tan
pequeños tienen mayor área superficial
dicha área permite que ocurra el
intercambio de oxígeno y nutrientes con
las células que estoy dibujando que los
necesitan por lo que la sangre brinda
oxígeno a estas células cuando la sangre
pasa de lecho capilar ha perdido todo su
oxígeno y por eso es de color azul esa
sangre regresa al corazón aquino lo
dibuje pero la sangre también pasa por
los pulmones para obtener nuevo oxígeno
y repite el ciclo de nuevo llevando
oxígeno este es un ciclo cerrado que se
repite sin cesar pero esto tiene un
problema el corazón tiene que bombear
con bastante fuerza para que la sangre
llegue a todas
partes con la rapidez necesaria para
alimentar a todas las células del cuerpo
esto significa que la presión que ejerce
el corazón es muy alta por lo que hay
presión alta en el corazón y presión
alta en los vasos sanguíneos lo que hace
esto es forzar ciertos fluidos a salir
de los vasos sanguíneos en particular
fuera de estos capilares ese fluido que
es forzado a salir no es necesariamente
sangre porque por ejemplo los glóbulos
rojos que se encuentran en la sangre son
demasiado grandes como para ser
expulsados pero la parte más acuosa de
la sangre como el plasma si sale eso es
lo que termina aquí y ese fluido se
entremezcla con las células que se
encuentran fuera de los capilares y se
acumula esto es un problema porque si
esto continuará perderíamos
prácticamente todo el fluido en la
sangre y tendríamos una acumulación de
fluido aquí lo que se volvería
insostenible aquí es donde entra el
sistema linfático y este es el problema
que soluciona el sistema linfático es
otro sistema de tuberías
voy a tratar de dibujar aquí tiene esos
vasos que parecen surgir de ninguna
parte y recolectan este fluido de manera
que lo reincorporan a la circulación
regresando a la sangre de esta forma
regresa y la sangre continúa circulando
por lo que ahora tenemos una situación
sostenible a estos vasos de aquí les
llamamos vasos linfáticos y son un poco
diferentes de los vasos sanguíneos
porque no forman un ciclo cerrado la
linfa que es como se llama el fluido que
es expulsado de los vasos sanguíneos la
linfa entra aquí y es llevada a los
vasos sanguíneos de aquí no regresa
donde inicio esta es la explicación
básica del por qué necesitamos un
sistema linfático pero veamos esto con
mayor detalle veamos un acercamiento de
uno de estos capilares vamos a dibujarlo
con cierta rotación aquí espero que no
los confundan estas son las células
endoteliales que revisten al capilar y
vamos a estudiar cómo es que el fluido
es expulsado
conforme recorremos este capilar la
sangre se va a quedar sin oxígeno
por esto cambio el color de estas
células aunque en realidad las células
endoteliales no cambian de color así así
que al pasar por el capilar tenemos
estos glóbulos rojos que trato de
dibujar como pequeños discos aquí
entonces tenemos los glóbulos rojos
también tenemos mucha agua y finalmente
tenemos algunas proteínas algunas
proteínas son más grandes que otras por
lo que las dibujamos en varios tamaños
todo esto está presente en la sangre y
debido a la presión alta es expulsado la
primera pregunta es exactamente cómo y
por dónde es expulsado la respuesta es
que pasa entre las células las células
no se encuentran tan pegadas entre sí
como para evitar que estas cosas salgan
pero si están lo suficientemente juntas
como para evitar que salgan las cosas
más grandes por lo que los glóbulos
rojos y las proteínas más grandes se
quedan adentro lo que sale es algo del
agua y algunas de las proteínas más
pequeñas que voy a dibujar así
y para cuando la sangre llega al otro
extremo del capilar ya ha perdido
algunas de las proteínas más pequeñas y
algo de este fluido vamos a ilustrarlo
borrando algunas de estas cosas por lo
que la concentración de proteínas más
grandes es mayor así como la
concentración de glóbulos rojos así que
tenemos una mayor concentración de
solutos al final del capilar comparado
con lo que tenemos al principio y la
razón por la que menciono esto es porque
hay una sutil complicación aquí pues
aunque lo que se va a convertir en linfa
es expulsado por el capilar aquí algo
del fluido va a regresar por acá al vaso
sanguíneo y para comprender esto
necesitamos saber que la concentración
de solutos es mayor aquí lo que ocasiona
una mayor presión osmótica que va a
jalar el fluido hacia adentro y para
entender esto también tenemos que saber
que la presión hidrostática regular es
menor en la parte final del capilar en
comparación con la parte inicial así que
la presión disminuye la presión era lo
que empujaba la linfa hacia afuera del
vaso sanguíneo aquí
ahora tenemos menos presión que expulse
el líquido y más líquido que es atraído
hacia adentro debido a la presión
osmótica que es ocasionada por el
aumento en la concentración de solutos
por lo que aquí algo del fluido y de las
proteínas más pequeñas podrían ser
atraídas hacia adentro ahora es posible
que se sientan un poco confundidos
porque dije que el fluido era expulsado
fuera de los vasos sanguíneos y después
dije que el fluido era expulsado y
después jalado hacia adentro pero el
hecho es que es más el fluido que se
expulsa que el que vuelve a entrar así
que vamos a dibujar estas flechas un
poco más grandes salen más de lo que
regresa de manera que el resultado neto
del viaje de la sangre a través de este
capilar es que al final la linfa es
expulsada ahora saben un poco más el
detalle sobre cómo y por qué tenemos
linfa y quizás se pregunten por qué no
se juntan más estas células y cierran
sus conexiones para evitar que salgan
las cosas la respuesta es que debemos
recordar que tenemos otras células por
acá que quieren nutrirse
quieren obtener glucosa y otras cosas
por el estilo de la sangre por lo que es
importante que puedan pasar por este
espacio
las pequeñas moléculas de glucosa y las
pequeñas moléculas de proteínas como las
hormonas para que estén cerca de estas
células y puedan interactuar con ellas
básicamente si estas células
endoteliales en los capilares estuvieran
muy juntas entre sí entonces todas estas
células en el cuerpo quedarían aisladas
y quizá también se pregunten si estas
brechas son necesarias para que el
oxígeno pase por ellas hacia las células
pero el oxígeno es diferente es muy
pequeño su molécula está formada por dos
átomos por lo que el oxígeno puede
atravesar las células de las paredes y
llegar a donde sea necesario espero que
esto les haya dado una mejor idea de
cómo la linfa se forma a partir de los
capilares como mucha de ella es
expulsada y algo de ella vuelve a entrar
finalmente quiero dibujar una figura
humana medio fea y hacer énfasis en que
básicamente hay capilares por todo el
cuerpo que alimentan a todos los
músculos y diferentes
tejidos y es por ese motivo que se
necesitan vasos linfáticos para
recuperar la linfa de prácticamente todo
el cuerpo hay vasos linfáticos en las
piernas en los brazos y por todas partes
en cierto sentido se parecen un poco a
los vasos sanguíneos ya que comienzan
siendo muy pequeños muchos de ellos se
juntan y forman un vaso linfático más
grande ese vaso linfático a su vez se
junta con otro vaso linfático más grande
y forman uno aún mayor y así
sucesivamente
es como si comenzaran siendo capilares
que luego se unen y forman unos más
grandes cada vez aunque claro que tienen
la gran diferencia con respecto a los
vasos sanguíneos de que no forman un
ciclo cerrado al final cuando se
consolidan en grandes vasos linfáticos
vacían su contenido de vuelta al flujo
sanguíneo